welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like the answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and Speaker of amazing facts
[Music]
June 1st
2016 the world's longest and deepest
tunnel called the Gotthard base tunnel
opened in Switzerland nearly seven
decades after it was first proposed and
20 years after construction began the 35
mile long twin bore tunnel now creates a
high-speed rail link under the Swiss
Alps the new route will now connect
Europe's busiest tunnel in the port of
rotterdam in the North Sea with Genoa
Italy in the Mediterranean in record
time and take a million trucks off the
road that will now go by train instead
when fully operational around 260
freight trains and 65 passenger trains
are expected to travel through the two
parallel tunnels every day the trains
will reach speeds approaching a hundred
miles an hour for Freight and up to a
hundred and fifty five miles an hour for
passengers the Gotthard base tunnel is
also the deepest railway tunnel in the
world with a maximum depth of
approximately
7,500 feet or about a mile and a half
the new 12.5 billion dollar tunnel
required approximately
2,600 workers often laboring
around-the-clock in humid noisy dusty
and blistering hot conditions in fact
we're not for so powerful ventilation
tunnels the temperature inside the
mountain would pass a hundred and
fifteen degrees nine workers died while
building the record-breaking tunnel
under Europe's largest mountains you
know the Bible says that if you have
enough faith you can not only go through
mountains you can move them stay with us
friends we're gonna talk about this on
today's edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
that's one eight hundred four six three
seventy to ninety seven let's get to our
first Bible question with pastor Doug
Batchelor and our co-host pastors Jean
Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and this is the time if you
have a Bible question there's nothing we
enjoy more than searching the word with
you all you have to do is call in we
have plenty of lines open and you'll
have a real good chance of getting your
question on tonight's program here's the
number again 800 God says we use the
Bible as our resource eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven one more
time 800 four six three seven two nine
seven with your Bible questions in the
studio we'll be giving another resource
number later my name is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross good evening
listening friends and pastor Doug as
usual let's start the program with
prayer dear father in having me thank
you once again that we're able to open
up your word and study together and we
ask your blessing upon this program or
we ask a special blessing on those
listening wherever they might be and
Lord lead us to a clearer understanding
of the Bible and it's important
teachings for we ask this in Jesus name
Amen amen
well pastor doc I'm sure you've been
through some long tunnels in your
travels I know I've been through several
but to travel through at all that is 35
miles long that must be quite something
it is oh well I've traveled through some
tunnels but I've never been through one
that long and I've been through some
I've driven through some tunnels in the
Alps now you probably have too but
waking you can't imagine you'd probably
get claustrophobia but if the trains
going 155 miles an hour you would not be
under the mountain very long I guess
that'd be about 15 20 minutes right but
you know it makes me think about that
verse where Jesus said in Matthew
chapter 11 I'm sorry mark 11 verse 22 he
said to them have faith in God for
assuredly I say to you whoever says to
this mountain be removed and cast into
the sea and does not doubt in his heart
but believes those things that he says
will be done he'll have whatever he says
jesus said if you have faith you can
move mountains and when I first read
that verse I thought that meant you have
enough faith that you can move masses of
dirt but then I read another place in
the Bible where it says that God takes
our sins and cast them into the depths
of the sea so the Lord isn't just
talking about our having faith to move
mountains and cast them into the sea
everyone is really struggling under the
curse of a mountain of sin and we wonder
how can we have victory over these
battles and through faith all things can
be done and we can have victory over all
kinds of habits and practices and some
people a struggle they resist a
temptation and fallen for years and they
wonder can I ever be free of whatever
this addiction is or whatever this bad
pattern is and you know the Bible says
that you can do all things through
Christ is it possible without living as
a captive to sin maybe you'd like to
know about that and if you do have faith
because we've got a free book for you we
have a book it's cold is it possible to
live without sinning we'll be happy to
send this to anybody who calls and asks
all you'll need to do is call our
resource phone number in the number is
883 five six seven four seven in that's
808 three five six seven four seven you
can ask for the book called is it
possible to live without sinning I think
you'll be encouraged as you read that
book a lot of scripture references there
one more time the number to call is 808
three five six seven four seven that is
the resource phone line and after the
book is that possible to live without
sinning if you have a Bible question the
phone line here to the studio with your
Bible question is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 God says
four six three seven two nine seven well
pastor doc I think we're ready for our
first caller this evening we have Joseph
who is listening in Virginia Joseph
welcome to the program
hello Joseph you on the air
yes dog thanks for accepting my call
absolutely how can we help you tonight
well the question is about the
for signs in Matthew 24:29 I don't know
the official interpretation but maybe a
certain group they interpret those signs
to mean events that happened in like the
year
1755 the earthquake and then 1780 the
dark day and then
1833 the stars falling I want to offer
you a better interpretation what are you
asking a question what are you asking a
question well I want to offer you this
that's all they're all
whatsoever because you're getting ready
to offer something to me and you haven't
heard what I believe give me a second to
explain what this verse says and then
I'll let you make a statement okay okay
all right that sounds fair cuz our
listeners don't know what verse we're
talking about right now for friends in
Matthew chapter 24 verse 29 Jesus is
talking about signs of the second coming
and he says immediately after the
tribulation of those days the Sun will
be darkened the moon will not give its
light the Stars will fall from heaven
the powers of heaven will be shaken then
the sign of the Son of Man will appear
in heaven and all the tribes of the
earth will mourn and they'll see the Son
of man coming in the clouds of heaven
with power and great glory and I think
what Joseph is referring to is there are
a couple of views regarding this
prophecy first of all there's what you
call the historic fulfillment when you
can look over the panorama of history
there was a Great Tribulation of the
Dark Ages there was a great earthquake
that happened in Europe and what they
call the Lisbon earthquake was one of
the greatest earthquakes at the time
there was a day called the dark day in
another day when the stars fell and
these are all in the encyclopedia and so
on top of the historic fulfillment
there's also a literal fulfillment these
things Joseph are going to happen
literally in quick succession before the
second coming there will be a great time
of trouble just before Jesus comes the
Sun will be darkened the moon will not
give its light the Stars will fall the
heavens will roll together and Jesus
will come
Oh a lot of prophecies Christ gives have
what you call a dual application and
when he's answering questions in Matthew
24 they're asking him at the beginning
of Matthew 24 the disciples say when
will this be the destruction of
Jerusalem what will be the signs of your
coming and the end of the world and you
can even see in some places you'd say
it's a try fulfillment because he's
telling the destruction of Jerusalem
then he gives a panorama historically of
the signs of the second coming and then
he talks about things that will happen
in quick succession at the end of the
world so now go ahead I I cut you off
because I figured people listening we're
we're what we're talking about
yes I want to give you a alternative
explanation in which one thing causes
all those signs as
distinct or in contrast to the other
explanation where all those things are
separate to have separate clauses now my
view is that one the the thing that
causes the the Sun to turn black and the
moon turn red would be
the same thing that causes the stars of
all the stars would be man-made stars
nuclear warheads they become fireballs
and at that time there is a thing called
wave interference where the twelve of
one light wave of running to the crest
of another white light wave and they
cancel each other out and there's a
moment of darkness now that would take
care of the Sun blackening the
and the stars falling and the the next
thing would be the sky rolling up like a
scroll
that's from a revelation six of course
but the idea is it wouldn't be the sky
rolling up it would be the mushroom
clouds in the sky
the horizontal rings so you think that
yep I and we can't go too long Joseph so
you think that this is going to be in
connection with like a nuclear event
fulfill the
sky the party like roll being rolled up
finally there's number four is the move
ready knee that would be oh the last
thing that happens and it would it would
take a few hours and days for all the
suit from our cities where their cities
used to be all that suit would rise into
the sky and lit a filter and block out
well you know yeah that even happens
right now Joseph when there's a forest
fire yeah the Sun goes dark the moon
turns to blood and whenever there were
times of war they often would burn
fields and burn cities and the sky would
go dark the moon looked like blood and
so you can find that same phrase in the
book of Joel yeah there may be a nuclear
event at the end of time but I don't
believe that's what's gonna cause these
things to happen in quick succession but
we do appreciate your calling and
sharing these thoughts you know we do
have a study guide talking about events
associated with the second coming of
Jesus it's called the ultimate
deliverance and Joseph I think you'll
enjoy studying this for anyone wanting
to learn more about events associated
with how Jesus will come and when he
will come and that kind of thing give us
a call on our resource phone number the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
in ask for the study guide called the
ultimate deliverance again that number
is 885 67 47 a next caller is Megan
listening from South Dakota Megan
welcome to the program
hi Megan you there
hi thanks for calling and your question
my is we've been doing
Bible studies with some people and we
just we're doing one on if God created
the devil or not and we came across the
Bible verse from first and chapter 3
verse 8 yeah where it talks about the
double sin
and brought up we were wondering the
beginning of what well let me read this
for everybody and this is first John 3:8
and it says hew sins is of the devil for
the devil has sinned from the beginning
for this purpose the Son of God was
manifested that he might destroy the
works of the devil well the devil sinned
from the beginning of the time he became
the devil
he before he was sinful he was known as
Lucifer he was a beautiful unfallen
angel and when it says from the
beginning that's specifically talking
about the beginning of our world John in
his other letters often talks about the
beginning and
so you know from all the way back at the
beginning with Adam and Eve the devil
sin and he inspired or incited man to
sin and this is what I think he's
talking about but I'm not sure am I
asking what your asset wait am i
answering what you're asking no I I
think you did yes but that makes more
sense I just was I wasn't sure how to
explain that but
yeah if John uses you know beginning you
know frequently to mean the beginning of
our world that makes a lot of
yeah he doesn't even in Revelation it
talks about the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world and John wrote
revelation as well so he often focuses
about you know from the very beginning
God activated a plan to save man and the
devil was right there in the garden at
the beginning yeah that was after his
fall and
I think John also talks about him being
a murderer
meaning he inspired Cain to kill his
brother
Abel and that's again at the beginning
there's no record of angels murdering
each other before man was made I
appreciate your question Megan and thank
you for calling we do of course you've
got the lesson it sounds like so what
else you know for anyone else wanting to
learn more about that we have a lesson
called did God create a devil and we'll
be happy to send it to anyone who calls
an ass again the number is 883 five six
seven four seven you can answer this
study guide called dead god create a
devil if you have a Bible question the
phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven with
your Bible question that's 800 four 63
72 97 i mexico least even listening in
new york stephen you're on the air
evening how can we help you tonight
pleasure talks in my question to you
one specifically men in this race from
the Bible first shall be last and the
last shall be first
well Jesus is talking about that in the
world it actually that applies to and by
the way you find that in Matthew
nineteen thirty you find it in mark
10:31 many who are first will be last
and the last will be first there's going
to be a great reversal of values when we
get to the
Judgment Day
you know people in this world they think
that the rich are the ones who are
blessed and successful and Jesus said no
the poor in spirit will inherit the
kingdom
you know people make a big deal about
pride in this world but in God's eyes
humility is what matters
in this world is how much you get in
God's economy it's how much you give
is so just in so many ways it's
different and
Jesus was speaking to the Jewish nation
and many of the leaders thought we are
the chosen people we are Abraham's seed
we have a right we've inherited this we
have the Word of God and God you know
we're the chosen people and
Jesus was saying well you know the
gospel is going to go to the Gentiles
the people that you call dogs and so
you'll be surprised that the last or the
lowest in your opinion will be the
highest and some of the highest in your
opinion will be the lowest so good yeah
it Jesus was just basically that's a
statement it covers a whole
kaleidoscope of principles in comparing
Jesus teachings with the way the devil
in the world value things
absolutely thank you it's a great
question if you have a Bible question
the phone line here to the studio is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven that's 804 63 72 97 and we
have James is listening on the road in
South Carolina James welcome to the
program
thank you so much he's for taking my
call my question is in regard to someone
who I was listening to a program prior
to yours on XM and I called in the
pastor had given a
biblical definition of an adulterous
marriage someone who marries someone
unlawfully according to scripture and
his remedy I wonder take was that those
people should divorce my question to him
was if those people came to a saving
knowledge of Jesus Christ after their
marriage and
discovered that they had actually
entered into an adulterous marriage by
one of the other not lawfully being
divorced what was the remedy he was
alluding to the fact that they should
divorce what is your take on that
whether the person entered the marriage
knowingly or unknowingly into Ana what
was defined as an adulterous marriage
well it's sort of like
the wheat and the tares parable and once
you sow the weeds among the tares if you
try to pluck him up and separate him you
make things worse that's what the in the
parable it teaches he just got to let it
go when King David entered into an
adulterous marriage with Bathsheba they
were punished for their sin they were
both ostensibly believers in God and
they sinned and
they suffered for their sin and it talks
about how when Nathan confronted David
he said you have taken the wife of Uriah
well at that point David was married to
Bathsheba Uriah was dead Nathan didn't
say God did not tell Nathan to say you
need to divorce Bathsheba even after
their first baby died you would have
thought well they have no children now
they should divorce but you know what
the Bible says God says he forgave David
David knew his wife they had another son
together who was Solomon who ended up
becoming King in a ancestor of Jesus
so you you can't unscramble scrambled
eggs and the people enter into a
marriage especially if there's children
involved the idea then that they're
supposed to now divorce because they
didn't have biblical grounds for
marriage and you know in some cases you
have people that discover are become
convicted about their their marriage
twenty years after they entered into a
divorce or a an adulterous relationship
but you know I'd say once you're married
you're married because you made another
covenant usually marriage is associated
with a series of vows before God and so
how are you going to make things right
by breaking your second vows see what
I'm saying
with you a hundred percent I'm so
thankful for your program
[Music]
strongly believe the previous teacher
was in grave error and I know that
others like myself may have been
listening to the show and I would wanted
another perspective because you know he
was quoting once in mark when Herod was
confronted by John the Baptist and said
it is not lawful for you to have her and
he asked me what did I think that John
expected here to do but my answer was I
think he expected John to respond to the
law but the teacher gave no provision
for the the New Covenant the great
underwear
exactly we confess our sin
you know something I'm gonna have to
look up is just to find out if I don't
even know if it says that Herodias was
Herod's wife it says he had his
brother's wife it's almost like she does
moved in so I'm not sure you know she
had a stepdaughter
I'm not sure it may say that they were
married I've got to look that up but
either way
you know when people
when they're married like that you know
I I can't find the only places where God
tells someone to put away his wife is in
situations of polygamy he told Abraham
to put away Hagar because you're not
supposed to have more than one wife at a
time and
so that would be a case for that anyway
he appreciate your good James that's
important thank you very much and by the
way we do have a book that anyone
listening out there I think you
understand me sings James but we have a
book called marriage divorce and
remarriage that specifically addresses
what the Bible says about this we know
we're not guessing we know there's
listeners out there now that are
struggling with these issues and
wondering what does the Bible say about
marriage divorce and remarriage call
amazing facts we will send you this book
and do we just do it by faith and
believing people will support the
ministry and it'll give you a lot of
good Bible answers the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again the books called
marriage divorce and remarriage 808
three five six seven four seven and if
you have a Bible question the phone line
here to the studio is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven we've got Nancy
listening in South Carolina Nancy
welcome to the program hello yes we're
so happy to talk to you my question is
we're not to tell bear or gossip but is
it is it the same if you relate to your
husband you're supposed to be one and
talk about community gossip to him well
if first of all you should be able to
convite confide in your spouse but when
you it's one thing to talk about genuine
concerns but if through the course of
the day a husband or wife you know
becomes privy to gossip that a person is
not going to be edified by
repeating or someone else hearing you
know you're not under obligation to to
God to just kind of repeat all the
gossip that you've heard
so you know I know I try to confer with
my wife and tell her things that I think
are relevant that we can pray about or
that you know maybe genuine concern I
hear all kinds of things as a pastor
especially if people if you're
counseling people counseled with a
pastor in confidence and you hear a lot
of things and you pray for them and you
just leave it between you and God and
that person and so those things should
be kept in confidence
and what do you think Bess Ross yeah
absolutely you know I think in that case
pastor day if you if you sharing with
somebody or somebody sharing with you
and it's in confidence especially if you
providing some counsel to them some of
those things you probably don't want to
share with your spouse because you don't
want to affect their relationship
specially with the church member you
don't want them to look at that person
differently or you know maybe these
things that they've done that they don't
want people to know about and it's just
I think it's correct to if it's spoken
in confidence to to be quiet about it
it's different than just sharing general
things with your spouse but I think we
should be free to share those things
yeah yeah you know if we hear that a
person out there is had a tragedy in the
family and they need prayer you share
that together and those would be the
things but if you hear you know
scandalous where there's just a whole
lot of gossip on Facebook these days you
could get consumed listening to all that
but it's been a lot of time but anyway I
think you get the point and so you know
does that make sense Nancy and I
appreciate your advice all right hey
thank you very much thanks for your
question annex coli's Gary listening in
Dallas Texas Gary welcome to the program
hi good evening evening
yes so I had a question about
Old Testament there's two passages that
I found I think there might be a couple
more but they're kind of parallel Joshua
2419 and the second part of the verse
Josh was saying he's talking about God
he says he will not forgive your
transgressions nor your sins and then
also in Exodus 23 21
he says you know don't provoke him for
he will not pardon your transgressions I
know and everything else in the Bible
seems to say God does for a given part
and in fact that's the main message of
the Scriptures
so you're wondering is this this sounds
like a contradiction right some
inconsistencies I'm just wondering for
some clarity well first of all with both
Moses who's in Exodus and Joshua who's
in the book of Joshua they both
understood the whole sacrificial system
was built around
seeking forgiveness from God for sin so
they knew that God was a merciful God
and when God revealed himself pastor
Russ I forget the verse for God Moses
says show me your glory and the Lord
revealed his glory and is a statement
that it Moses makes about God
long-suffering merciful forgiving
transgression and equity and sin and
that matter of fact that might be the
one you're quoting there in Exodus right
now
but I think that Joshua let me look at
that verse in 19 says Joshua said to the
people you cannot serve the Lord for
he's a holy God he's a jealous God
you'll not forgive your transgressions
nor your sins if you forsake the Lord
and serve foreign gods so he's saying he
won't forgive if they forsake the Lord
of course he does forgive when we repent
of our sins and
you can kill him out of 10 yeah so many
other things in the Bible are pretty
clear that God is a merciful
long-suffering forgiving god what was
that verse it's in Exodus chapter 33
beginning verse 22 yeah says the same
thing there if you repent he'll forgive
we'll be right back friends
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth calm
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes
heroes of great deeds
great love
and great sacrifice
but behind them is another hero hidden
in plain sight amid the shadows
he was there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light
seeing Jesus in all the Bible a new book
by Doug Batchelor
get your copy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767
the program.i
evening thanks are you done better than
we deserve how are you doing yeah good
evening pastors so I've done I've got a
hard question for you guys it has to do
with in the book of Revelation
there's
John witnesses the dragon making war
with you know Michael and the Archangels
and and cast out of heaven it's very
descriptive but right prior right prior
to that there's something that happens
with this woman figure
heavenly woman's figure
giving birth to the Son of God I believe
man child yeah and and and you know and
then that the debt the dragon goes after
is the son of God and you know that's
right after that Michael and angels you
know go to go to war with him and he's
cast out so III wonder why we don't look
to scripture more as the source of
understanding of why of why Satan was
cast out of heaven
well it's interesting you would say that
because we do actually
talk quite a bit and amazing facts has
written quite a bit about revelation 12
and it's one of my favorite studies in
the whole book you've got the whole plan
of salvation wrapped up in that story
you've got the battle between the dragon
and the woman which takes you all the
way back to the Garden of Eden where God
said that the seed of the woman would
crush the Serpent's head and the serpent
would bruise the heel of the seed of the
woman and seed of the woman run that
their church so you know you find this
battle between the dragon it tells us in
Revelation that old serpent called the
dragon and Satan we know that that
serpent that dragon is the devil and he
has been at war with the woman a woman
is a symbolic term in prophecy for the
church or the Bride of Christ Bible says
husband's love your wives as Christ
loved the church and God has likened his
church his people his daughter of Zion
to a woman and so all through the Bible
you've got that symbolism and this
beautiful woman clothed with the Sun
Moon and stars in Revelation is the
church jesus said to the church you are
the light of the world God made the Sun
Moon and stars natural light and so
you've got this battle you're the man
child she brings forth is the Christ and
of course the dragon wants to devour
that child that's why King Herod sent
his soldiers into Bethlehem to destroy
the babies when Jesus was born that's
why Pharaoh tried to kill all the babies
in in Egypt in atholea tried to kill the
seed of David they were all trying to
kill or prevent the Messiah from coming
there's been this war but now Christ
ascended to heaven the dragon can't
reach Christ any more the devil now
takes his wrath out on the people who
reflect Christ the church and so he goes
after the woman and she flees into the
wilderness so I could go on and on it's
just so great we got a whole lesson on
this study what about some of the other
details like you know on a third of the
you know angels you know followed him
the dragon and they were cast out know
no room was left for them in heaven
anymore and they were cast the earth
that old serpent
so I see like a Cana logical event when
I read that and I just wonder because
it's so detailed in the chronology I
wonder if it's more literal than
symbolic like that this is really what
happened well you know just a little bit
more to that it's interesting when it
talks about this there's two castings
there is a casting out and there is a
casting down and the casting out and the
casting down is not necessarily the same
event the casting out is the result of
this war in heaven and Satan and his
angels are expelled but there is a
casting down to the earth that occurs at
the cross where all the universe sees
the true nature of the devil and he's
attempt well he was successful in
you know crucifying Christ I mean
inspiring people to crucify him so he
was cast down to the earth prior to that
you read about how that there was this
meeting with the sons of God and Satan
came from the earth and it seemed that
he sort of claimed to be the
representative of Earth but after the
cross
Satan no longer is the representative of
Earth but Christ is now the
representative of Earth and then right
after that where it says II was cast
under the earth then it says they
overcame by the blood of the Lamb by the
word of their testimony so there are
these two events that's been highlighted
they in Revelation 12 yeah we actually
have a lesson if you'd like Ethan we
will send you a free lesson that talks
about the Bride of Christ yeah that's
revelation 12 is old lesson the number
to call is 883 five six seven four seven
that is the study guide and you can ask
for the lesson called the Bride of
Christ eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and if you have a
Bible question the phone line here to
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven 804 63 72
97 my next call is Larry listening in
North Carolina Larry welcome to the
program hello about a couple of verses
in Revelation one of them is chapter two
verse nine and the others chapter three
verse nine and in both verses it's
talking about the synagogue of Satan and
the people are the churches they don't
seem to be Ben warned about these people
and I'm being warned about what these
people say it's just like Lord tells
them you know a prophecy about what's
going to happen to these any thoughts on
these two verses well yes when it talks
in revelation about the synagogue of
Satan that word their synagogue means
gathering or congregation of Satan and
obviously for every truth that Jesus has
the devil's got a counterfeit and the
devil has counterfeit Gospels and he's
got counterfeit Church and
Jesus said the day is coming thing is
John chapter 16 when those who kill you
will think they're serving God it's like
when Paul was killing Christians he was
part at that time of the synagogue of
satan' and
you know Jesus said if you're not with
him you're against him and we all know
there's plenty of people that go to
church that aren't not with Christ and
so there's a whole counterfeit religion
and also during the time period that we
read about there in revelation of God's
prophetic it's talking about events that
transpired during the Christian era
there were many pagan rituals and
practices that found their way into the
church and people were sitting aside the
commandments of God in following these
pagan rituals and practices and in
essence they they were thinking they're
worshiping God but they're actually
following man-made tradition and that's
something that's alluded to there in
their verse yep so just go ahead Larry
they were actually they weren't been
warned about them they would just tell
what was going to happened to him and I
don't see why that it would be a bad
thing why would be so bad to claim it's
the people to claim they were a Jew if
they're not what would that be so bad I
don't understand
well you not just Judaism it's for a
person to claim being a follower of God
when they're not really a follower of
God and
yeah we certainly have it you know we've
got some study guides that actually
talked about you know being a genuine
Christian and
you we have a book called alone in the
crowd that deals with that and you know
we'll send you a free copy for that if
you like Larry or anyone that's the
number to call is 808 three five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book called alone in the crowd again
that's 808 three five six seven four
seven and if you have a Bible question
the phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven a
next call is Alex listening in
Connecticut Alex welcome to the program
Alex you there
and your question today yes I would like
to ask a question about sight
if she's still
good for New Testament Christian because
Paul that Christ died on the cross oh
that loss
would be
[Music]
would not be what will follow anymore so
how can we still pay tight well where
does first first of all there are laws
that we no longer follow as New
Testament Christians we don't you know
circumcision doesn't matter the
sacrificing of lambs Jesus is our lamb
but some people have taken Paul's
statement to mean that we don't keep the
Ten Commandments anymore and obviously
it is still a sin to lie or kill or
steal for Christians so I think you
would agree there are laws that
Christians should still keep is that
right
that's right okay so yeah the Ten
Commandments you know that hasn't
changed that's eternal
and God has laws for like supporting his
work tithe was the law not just given to
the Levites tithe is first mentioned by
Abraham when Abraham won this battle
when he rescued a lot he gave tithes to
Melchizedek the priest then Jacob made a
promise and he said if Lord if you'll
bring me home again a tenth of all that
you give me I will give to you and he
did that he gave it to his his brother
Esau because his brother Esau was the
priest the land at the time and
then jesus said if you go to Matthew
chapter 23 I don't know if you've got a
pencil or a Bible handy but I can read
this to it it's easy to remember Matthew
23 20 three jesus said woe to you
scribes and Pharisees hypocrites for you
pay tithe of mint and anise and cumin
those are little herbs in the herb
garden in the Pharisees were so
legalistic they would count out ten
little parsley stalks and they'd give
one to the Lord a tenth and so they were
paying tithe on their herb gardens which
is pretty fastidious and then he said
Jesus said you've neglected the
weightier matters of the law justice and
mercy and faith these you ought to have
done now notice when he says Jesus says
without leaving the other undone in
other words keep paying your tithe but
don't be paying tithe on your herb
garden and forget about justice mercy
and faith and so the New Testament
principle forgiving is actually more
than tithe if you look in
Acts chapter two okay yeah you can you
hear me yeah if you look in Acts chapter
two it says that no man said that ought
that he had was his own but they all had
everything in common and the disciples
in Acts chapter four in Acts chapter
five they were selling their houses and
lands and bringing it to the church so
they were giving a lot more than 10% if
a person doesn't believe that tithe is
still a principle that should be
followed well then they should be
following the New Testament principle
that's gonna be a lot more than tithe
yeah I mean they were just liquidating
everything and supporting the work back
then so I would think as a very as a
basic minimum you know Christians should
still pay tithe we have a lesson on this
and we'll send it to you for free it's
got a lot of Scripture in it and it's
full of promises and encouragement
listen it's called In God We Trust and
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask to the study
guide called in god we trust' again 800
eight three five six seven four seven
our next caller is John and he's
listening in North Carolina John welcome
to the program you're on the air
John are you with us
my name yeah there you go probably at
the mute on how can we help you tonight
Nora yeah my question to you pastor is
about why God blame us or sin meaning I
want to give it some illustration and we
blame like a dog for barking or a bird
for flying or for fish
swims in the water they cannot blame
them because that's the nature and
that's how God created them in our case
we were created with the fall in nature
and that's why we sin and God blames us
for that sin because he gave us that
fall in nature that's why we sinned well
first of all he goes in your course
awesome go ahead I'm sorry finish I'll
let you finish and then he goes I'm
gonna send you the Savior so I'm like
uestion to you Pastor before to say
there were Lord Jesus Christ God created
us with a boat in nature and that's why
we sinned so I don't think it should be
any punishment or in nature that he gave
us to begin with all right I see what
you're saying I've asked the same
question before when I was a baby
Christian I thought Lord why would you
send me to hell for sinning if I'm born
with this propensity to sin and Lord you
created me so you must have made me with
this desire for sin and all humans sin
and rubella and then you're gonna you
know throw us and like a fire for doing
that and when I studied the Bible I
found that God actually didn't make us
that way God created man perfectly and
man was made with a free will Adam had
no desire or natural propensity to sin
but what happened is Adam then listened
to the devil who told him don't believe
God's Word
Adam developed the fallen nature which
he passed on to all his children God did
not create us fallen God created
everything good if you read in Genesis
everything God made it says it was good
good very good God hates sin God doesn't
tempt anybody to sin and so we are it's
true we are born in this enslaved
condition just like the children of
Israel were born in Egypt as slaves
because of a decision their ancestors
made the children of Israel didn't want
to be slaves they were born in slavery
so why would God allow well what God did
is he sent Moses to set them free we are
born with these sinful natures and sin a
it ends up causing all kinds of misery
in our lives when people drink they
suffer the results of it or if they
smoke or if they curse whatever it is it
ends up causing problems God wants to
save us from these problems that were
born with if a baby is born with you
know some kind of a medical problem and
the doctors can heal and save that baby
what we think will bless bless the
doctors we're born because of a decision
our parents made were these sinful
natures and God said I will give you a
new heart I will save you it's not God's
fault God is perfect God is good and he
wants to save us it's the fault of our
ancestors that we're all suffering with
this disease of sin now did that make
sense John gave us that bad heart to
begin with so now you know you're now
see that's it God did not give us a bad
heart God is offering to give us a good
heart we are born with a bad heart
because of a decision our parents made
to trust the devil talking about Adam
and Eve instead of trusting God so we're
not to blame not to blame God God is
good the Bible says I mean you can't
believe anything the Bible says if you
don't believe God is good it's very
clear god is love God is good God does
not want us to suffer if you just look
at the life of Jesus Jesus came down and
suffered like we can't even comprehend
to save us from suffering and in death
he doesn't look at that to see what
comes in yeah
no God we disagree we were born with
that and to begin with
[Music]
eight fires and they inject that syringe
in your blood and now you become a
positive and then I come and tell you
okay now since your HIV positive I love
you I'm gonna give you the medication so
he can get better but why would I do
that you're starting you see you're
starting with the son
that God is the one who's injected us
with this disease of sin he did not
that's what we're telling you you're
assuming that because we're born sinful
God must be responsible since he's a
Creator God created out of an eve at
perfect Adam and Eve our parents sinned
and we inherited this fallen nature from
them you know we this is a good question
because it's something that even the
disciples were asking Jesus there was a
man that was born blind and the
disciples said to Jesus well whose sin
did this Manson or his parents that he
was born blind and Jesus said no neither
he said nor his parents but that the
works of God might be revealed on an
education jesus said to the scribes and
Pharisees a woman who was healed in the
synagogue he said Satan has bound her
she was crippled over 18 years 18 years
and Jesus came to heal her so God is
there to fix the problem of sin he's not
the one that brings it on he hates a
human choice that brings it on yeah
absolutely hey do us a favor John you're
asking good questions I'm sure a lot of
people are keying in on what you're
asking because it seems very basic you
know here we are I asked the same
question we've got a study guide that
talks about the origin of sin we'd like
to send you a free copy why is there sin
in the world it talks about did God make
a devil and
please read that anyone out there if
you're wondering about that we sure hope
you'll read it it just gives you all the
scriptures on it you can decide yourself
the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and it's called did God create a devil
again eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven an equality skip and
he's listening in Albuquerque New Mexico
Kip welcome to the program thank you to
pastor Doug I've got a question on the
kills a dick okay this would be out of
Genesis 14 18 19 and 20 who was Mikkel
the dick as far as his position in with
Abraham and Jesus all right yeah
Melchizedek is a king that suddenly he's
a king priest that appears sort of out
of nowhere Abraham is coming back from
rescuing a lot from a battle with these
five kings up by Damascus and he's got
all of this bounty from the war and he
stops in a place called Salem later
known as Jerusalem
same place and there is this King there
he was a priest and his name is
Melchizedek and he's sort of a
mysterious figure right we don't know
for sure but I you know if you want to
do something interesting look at the
genealogies in your Bible you'll
probably find them online
one of the one of the patriarchs one of
the sons of Noah was actually still
alive
during the time of Melchizedek Shem
lived 600 years and some have wondered I
can't prove this and I don't know for
sure but one theory is that Melchizedek
was called the king of righteousness is
what his name means that Shem one of the
last survivors from before the flood
when he heard that Abraham had come to
the promised land to worship the true
God he left all the idolatry in
Mesopotamia and he came out with his
family and Abraham paid tithes to him
right Abraham called him a priest of the
Most High God what priest would be
higher than Abraham and he was a type of
Jesus no kiss adecco is not Jesus he was
a real person but he's a type of Jesus
and Paul says and I think it's Hebrews
in the New Testament he said without
beginning or end of days meaning
Melchizedek there's no genealogy that
tells where he came from there's no
follow-up that tells where he went he
just appears and he brings forth bread
and wine Jesus in the Covenant brings
bread and wine at the Last Supper so
he's a type of Christ that's Hebrews
chapter 7 verse 3 so I hope that helps a
little bit but yeah you're on the right
track there Kip and pray that's a
blessing we're gonna try and take one or
two more calls before our time
evaporates we have Virginia listening
Orlando Florida Virginia welcome to the
program
Virginia are you there
Virginia Orlando yes okay hi yeah please
it's important for us to keep the
Sabbath today during our time yeah you
know we had a caller a minute ago who is
asking about the law and we said that
yeah there are some ceremony laws New
Testament Christians don't need to worry
about but the Ten Commandments are not
God's Ten recommendations they existed
even before Mount Sinai it was wrong to
commit adultery back in the days of
Joseph it was wrong to murder back in
the days of Cain and it was wrong to you
know lie
so the Ten Commandments I mean most
churches agree with all the commandments
some don't agree with the one about
idolatry but it's still there the New
Testaments clear keep yourself from
idols and one of the Ten Commandments
that begins where the word remember is
the Sabbath and so obviously we still
need that time of rest we still need
that time of worship and so of course
God wants us to continue to keep the
Sabbath day you know we have a study
guide called the last day of history and
it kind of deals with us and looks at
what the Bible is to say about the
Sabbath we'll be happy to send this to
anybody who gives us a call and asks the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and again you can ask for the study
guide called the last day of history
amen Virginia we're gonna try and take
one more call and so I hope that helps
your question our next call E is Robert
listening from Washington Robert welcome
to the program
yeah I meet it hey and you did real
quick though because we're running short
on time
okay this is questions regarding isaiah
66 22 and 23 or 23 and 24 okay
you you want to read that you want us to
read it
okay you all right Isaiah 66 and you
said 23 and 24
it says for as the new let me see and it
shall come to pass it from one new moon
to another and from one Sabbath to
another so all flesh come and worship
before me says the Lord and they'll go
forth and look upon the corpses of the
men who have transgressed against me and
it says for their worm do not die and
the fire is not quenched and they'll be
in abhorrence to all flesh this is
talking about that
people will always know that there has
been a judge that has fallen on the
wicket it says in Malachi chapter 4
you'll go forth and tread upon the
wicked for they will be ashes under the
soles of your feet we have a study guide
on that and I pray that you'll send for
it Robert
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world beyond the Great Wall the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
motion
southeast Ohio faith oxygen tisha Joey
China - the amazing facts Chinese
language website is now one of our most
visited websites we also translated
thousands of pieces of literature for
these nations what started out as
hundreds of followers is now in the
hundreds of thousands the impact of your
funds invested in sharing the
everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come you
know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry god bless you
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
WWF ag0 RG and sign up for our free
Bible study course and make sure to
check out our online bookstore at AF
bookstore comm which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
$887 macing facto RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]
hello friends we all know a marathon is
one of the longest and hardest races a
person can run but did you hear about
the ultra marathon that used to have in
Australia it was 544 miles from
Melbourne to Sydney it attracted as many
as 150 world-class athletes but then
something happened that no one would
ever forget in
1983 a 61 year old potato farmer named
cliff young decided to enter the race
people were very amused because he had
on rubber galoshes over his boots and
when the race began and all the runners
took off sure enough old cliff was left
behind shuffling along very slowly but
he was shuffling very persistently
normally during this seven-day race the
runners would go about 18 hours running
and then they'd sleep for six hours but
nobody ever told cliff that when the
other runners stopped to rest during the
night cliff just kept on running some
people were afraid old cliff was gonna
have a heart attack and they were asking
the race organizers to show mercy and
stop the crazy old man but he would have
none of it each day he was gaining on
the pack because when they were sleeping
he was plodding along during the last
night of the race cliff passed all of
these world-class athletes not only was
cliff able to run that 544 mile race
without dying he won beating all the
other racers by 9 hours breaking the
record and becoming a national hero in
the process what's really amazing is
when they told him that he had won the
$10,000 prize he looked confused and
said he didn't know there was a prize
and he decided to share it with the
other runners when asked how he was able
to run all night long could responded
that he grew up on a farm where they had
about 2,000 head of cattle and because
they couldn't afford horses used to have
to round them one foot sometimes running
two and three days non-stop so
throughout the race he just imagined he
was chasing after the cows and trying to
outrun a storm
old cliff secret was to keep on running
while others were sleeping you know the
Bible tells us that the race is not
necessarily to the Swift something like
Aesop's parable of the tortoise in the
hare the tortoise just kept on plodding
along that's why Jesus tells us in
Matthew 24:13 he that endures unto the
end the same will be saved now you might
slip and fall during the race you might
even get off to a bad start but in the
Christian race that we run the main
thing is you want to finish well keep on
running friends and don't give up
[Music]
for over 50 years amazing faxes shared
the wonderful news of salvation and
provided millions of Bible resources to
people all over the world we built
churches in India proclaim God's Word in
China and have sent free Bible studies
around the globe today's program and
free resources were made possible by our
ministry partners caring individuals
like you if you've been blessed by
amazing facts would you please consider
partnering with us to reach others with
the Bible truth your financial support
today will help keep programs like this
on the air so the blessings you've
received can be shared with others to
find out more about becoming a ministry
partner please visit our website at
amazing facts dot o-r-g
[Music]